almost all software developers should
have some understanding of uml
uml is a way to use diagrams to
visualize a system or database
it's used frequently in software
development to plan out software systems
this introduction to uml is from ava
coders
and welcome to the uml course for
beginners we'll look into the most
widely used diagrams they're basic
notation
and applications each diagram that we
will study in this course will be
supported with a practical example
of a system or a situation that can be
modeled
with its help i like to start this
course with a little introduction to uml
and a brief overview of each diagram how
does it look like
and what is it actually used for first
of all
uml stands for unified modeling language
which
according to the legend was developed
when some serious it people were fed up
with an ambiguous variety of circles
dashes stars and clouds uml 2.0
that we're going to study in this course
consists of
an integrated set of diagrams of various
agreed shapes
and forms designed to help system and
software developers to define
design visualize and document software
system artifacts
and in some cases some business models
uml
is a set of best engineering practices
that has proven to be effective
in modeling large and complex systems
and
is a very important part of
object-oriented software development
uml mainly uses graphical notation to
express
the software project's design uml helps
teams to communicate
explore potential designs and validate
software
architectural designs the purpose of uml
is to provide
a standardized annotation that can be
used by
all object-oriented methods as well as
selecting and
integrating best elements of the
precursor notations
uml has been designed for a wide range
of applications
hence it provides constructs for a wide
variety of systems
and activities for example distributed
systems
analysis system design and deployment
uml diagrams can be divided into two
main types
structure diagrams and behavior diagrams
there are seven types of structure
diagrams
composite structure diagram deployment
diagram
package diagram profile diagram
class diagram object diagram and
component diagram
behavior diagrams include activity
diagram
use case diagram state diagram
sequence diagram communication diagram
interaction overview diagram and timing
diagram
now a few words about each one of them
class diagram
is this central modeling technique that
is used in
almost all object oriented methods this
diagram describes the types of objects
in the system
and different kinds of static
relationships that exist
between them the three most important
types of relationships in class diagrams
but there are actually more of them are
association which represents
relationships between instances of types
for example
a person works for a company or a
company has
multiple offices inheritance which
corresponds directly to inheritance
in object oriented design and
aggregation which is a form of object
composition in
object oriented design component
diagrams illustrate
how components are put together to form
larger components or software systems
and illustrates the architecture of
software components
and dependencies between them these
software components can include
runtime components executable components
and
source code components deployment
diagram helps to model the physical
aspect of an object-oriented software
system
this is a block diagram that shows the
system architecture as
deployment or distribution of software
artifacts
artifacts represent specific elements in
the physical world
that are the result of the development
process the diagram
simulates the runtime configuration in a
static view and visualize the
distribution of artifacts in the
application in most cases this involves
simulating
hardware configurations along with the
software components that host them
object diagram is an instance of the
class diagram it shows a detailed
snapshot of the system state at a
particular point in time
the difference is that the class diagram
is an abstract model of classes and
their relationships however the object
diagram represents
an instance at a specific moment which
is concrete in nature the use of object
diagrams
is rather limited namely to show
examples of data structures
package diagram is a structural diagram
that shows packages and dependencies
between them
it allows us to display different views
of the system for example
it is easy to simulate a layered
application composite structure diagram
is similar to the class diagram and it
is a kind of
a component diagram used mainly in micro
level system modeling but it depicts
individual parts instead of whole
classes this is a type of static
structure diagram that shows the
internal structure of a class and
interactions that the structure
makes possible this diagram can include
internal parts
ports through which the parts can
communicate with each other or
through which the class instances can
communicate with various parts and
with the outside world as well as
connectors between
parts and ports composite structure
diagram is a set of interrelated
elements that interact at runtime to
achieve a specific goal each element
has a dedicated role in this
collaboration profile diagram
allows us to create domain and platform
specific stereotypes and define
relationships between them we can create
stereotypes by drawing shapes of
stereotypes and linking them to
composition
or generalization through a resource
oriented interface
we can also define and visualize
stereotype values
use case diagram describes the
functional requirements of a system
in terms of use cases in essence it is a
model of
intended functionality of the system use
cases
and its environment actors use cases
allow us to link
what we need from the system with how
the system
meets those needs activity diagrams are
graphical representations of workflows
of stepwise activities
and actions with the support of choice
iteration and concurrency they describe
the control flow of the target system
such as
exploring complex business rules and
operations
as well as describing the use cases and
business processes
in uml activity diagrams are meant for
modeling
both computational and organizational
processes
state machine diagram is a type of
diagram used in uml to describe
system behavior which is based on david
harrell's concept of state diagrams
state machine diagrams depict permitted
states and transitions as well as events
that affect those transitions
this diagram helps to visualize the
entire life cycle of
objects and thus helps to better
understand
state-based systems sequence diagram
models the interaction of object based
on a time
sequence it shows how objects interact
with each other
in a particular use case similar to
sequence diagram
the communication diagram is also used
to model the dynamic behavior of a use
case when compared to sequence diagram
communication diagram focuses more on
showing object collaborations
rather than the time sequence in fact
communication diagrams and sequence
diagrams are semantically equivalent
and one can be generated from another
interaction overview diagram
focuses on the overview of the flow of
control
of the interactions this is a variant of
activity diagram
where the nodes depicted are the
interactions or
interaction occurrences interaction
overview diagram
describes interactions in which messages
and lifelines are hidden we can link
up the real diagrams and achieve a high
degree of navigation between diagrams
within an interaction of your diagram
timing diagram
shows the behavior of the object or
objects at a given time period
in fact this is a special form of a
sequence diagram
and the differences between them are
that the axes are swapped so that the
time increases from left to right
and the lifelines are displayed in
separate compartments arranged
vertically
so why are there so many diagrams the
reason for this
is that this can help to examine the
system at different
angles and there can be many
participants involved in software
development
for example analysts architectures
coders
testers quality control customers
technical authors
these people are all interested in
different aspects of the system
and each requires a different level of
details
for example a coder would want to
understand the design of the system to
be able
later to convert this design into some
low-level code
in contrast a technical writer is
interested
in the behavior of the system as a whole
and would want to understand the
product's features
uml tries to be a language that all
those participants can benefit from and
possibly use
at least one of its diagrams uml class
diagram
illustrates the structure of the system
by describing
classes their attributes methods and
relationships between them just before
we begin discussing the diagram
let's remind ourselves what is a class
in a nutshell
class is a template for creating objects
as well as
representing objects initial state
attributes
and behavior methods each attribute has
its own type
each method has its own signature but in
the class diagram
only the class name is mandatory and it
makes sense
because even the best psychics will not
be able to guess
what this nameless square supposed to
mean or what it generally refers to so
let's take a look at the building blocks
of a class diagram starting with the
class itself
the name of the class is written in the
uppermost partition
followed by the class attributes with
their types written
after the column and finally the last
partition contains
methods the type that the method can
return is
written after the column in the method
signature you've probably noticed the
minuses and pluses before the class
attributes and methods these are the
access modifiers or class
visibility notation plus means public
miners private hash protected
and tilde means package local each
parameter in a method can also be
described
in terms of its direction with the
respect to the caller
in out in out for example
method 1 uses p1 as an input parameter
and the value of p1 is somehow used by
the method
and the method does not change p1
method 2 accepts p2 as an input output
parameter
the p2 value is somehow used by the
method
and it accepts the output value of the
method
and the method itself can change p2
method 3 uses p3 as the output parameter
in other words the parameter serves as a
repository for the output
value of the method we can use class
diagrams at different stages
of the software development lifecycle
therefore
we might want them to reflect a
different levels of specification
and thankfully there are three different
perspectives or levels of specification
that we can use
a conceptual perspective is when class
diagrams
are interpreted as describing entities
of the real world
thus if we choose conceptual perspective
we construct a diagram
that represents the concepts in the
domain these concepts
relate to classes that implement them
the conceptual perspective
is considered language independent a
specification perspective
is when diagrams are interpreted as
describing abstractions
of software or components with
specification
and interfaces but without any reference
to a specific
implementation thus if you look at the
specification perspective you can
generally see
some software interfaces but not
necessarily
their implementation and finally the
implementation
perspective is when diagrams are
interpreted
as a description of software
implementations in a particular
technology or programming language
thus if you choose to use this
perspective you can choose to depict
the actual software implementation now
let's have a look
at the relationships between classes i
will describe the six
main types of notation that are most
common
these are association inheritance
implementation dependency aggregation
and composition similar to relationships
connecting
objects associations connect classes in
order for there to be a connection
between classes
there must be an association between
them if we assume that we have two
classes that interact with each other a
continuous
connecting line should be drawn between
them indicating the association
in the diagram often we can also see a
verb
written above the line that conveys its
meaning in addition we can also specify
the
multiplicity that is the number of
objects
that can take part in the relationship
multiplicity is specified
as a comma separated list of intervals
where each
interval is represented as a minimum
maximum for example one student can
learn from many tutors
and a tutor can teach many students
inheritance sometimes it is also called
generalization
as the name implies this is a schematic
representation of the relationship
between
the parent class and its descendants the
hollow arrow
is always directed towards the parent
class a classic example of inheritance
depicts a square class a rectangle class
and a circle class as descendants of
their common parent class
we can connect each class with their
parent class separately or combine
those lines and draw one common arrow
line that connects all
common descendants with their parent if
the sentence inherits from an abstract
class
then the name of such parent class is
written in italics
realization usually this refers to the
relationships between
an interface and objects that implement
this interface for example the owner
interface
has methods for buying and selling
private property
and the relationships between the owner
interface and the person
and corporation classes that implement
this
interface are depicted by a dashed line
with an
arrowhead pointing at the interface
dependency when an
object one class uses an object of
another class in its method
and this object is not stored in any
field
then this kind of relationship is
modeled as a dependency
dependency is essentially a special case
of the association of two classes
in this case changes in one class will
inexorably entail
changes in the other for example this
person class
has a has read method with a book as an
input parameter which returns true if
for example the person has
read the book dependency is drawn with a
dashed line
with arrowhead pointing towards the
class on which
the method of another class could depend
aggregation
a special type of relationship between
classes when
one class is a composite part of another
for example a
programmer's workstation could consist
of a chair
a desk a computer and a fan
but when we delete the workstation class
we still
have all these classes but on their own
they no longer form
an aggregate class workstation
aggregation is shown as a continuous
align with an unfilled
diamond connected to the class which
represents the
aggregate composition is a type of
aggregation but this time
classes that form the aggregator class
are destroyed when the aggregator class
is destroyed for example our body is
made up of organs but they can't
function by themselves
composition is depicted similarly to
aggregation but this time
the diamond is solid and as a conclusion
to this topic i just want to remind you
that uml
is not so much about a pretty picture
uml is actually a powerful tool in the
programmer's toolkit
if you can understand and utilize it
properly say
get in the habit of drawing your class
diagram before you sit down and
actually code your next e-commerce
gaming financial
and whatnot project time invested in
drawing as
a synth and clear uml diagram will
eventually pay off
and can save your project from design
flows
and other errors you might encounter
without
a proper plan in front of you uml
component diagrams
are used for modeling physical aspects
of object oriented systems that are used
for
visualizing defining and documenting
component-based systems as well as
construction
executable systems using forward and
reverse engineering component diagrams
are essentially class diagrams that
focus on
system components that are often used to
model
the static implementation view of a
system
component diagram breaks down the system
under development
into various high levels of
functionality each component
is responsible for one clear goal within
the entire system
and interacts with other essential
elements only on a
need to know basis so how does it work
data
for example account and inspection id
flows into the component through the
port
on the right and gets converted to a
format that internal components can
utilize interfaces on the right are
known as
required interfaces they represent the
services the component
needs to fulfill its responsibilities
data
then passes through various connections
and other components before
it is output through the ports on the
left those interfaces on the left
are also known as provided interfaces
and other components of the system can
interact with them
in order to take advantage of the output
results
of the component it is important to note
that the internal components are
surrounded by a large box
which can represent the system as a
whole in that case there will be
no component symbol in the upper right
corner or a subsystem
or component of the overall system in
this case
the box itself is a component a
component
is a modular part of a system that
encapsulates its
content in uml 2.0 a component is drawn
as a rectangle with
optional compartments arranged
vertically the following example
shows two types of interface components
provided interface
is drawn with a complete circle at its
end and represents
the interface that the component
provides to the system
this symbol is known by the nickname
lollipop and is a shorthand for a
realization
relationship of an interface classifier
required interface
is indicated by a semicircle at the
end and as you might guess it indicates
the interface that the component needs
to perform a task
in both cases the interface's name is
placed
next to the interface symbol subsystem
classifier is a special kind
of a component classifier because of
this the subsystem notation element
inherits the same rules as the
componentation element
the only difference is that the
subsystem element is marked with the
keyword
subsystem instead of the keyword
component ports
are depicted with a square drawn along
the edge of the system or
a component a port is mainly used to
expose
required and provided component
interfaces
graphically a component diagram
resembles a system of components and
logical nodes connecting them
in general some relationships might
already be familiar to you as they are
widely used
in the class diagram but there are some
unique ones association
an association defines the semantic
relationship that can occur
between typed instances it is drawn as a
straight line connecting two or more
components
of the system composition composite
aggregation
is a strong form of aggregation that
requires
a part instance to be included in at
most
one composite at a time if a composite
is deleted
all its parts are usually deleted with
it
aggregation very similar to composition
but in this case
the child component can exist on its own
even without being
a part of the aggregator class
aggregation is drawn with a
hollow diamond pointing towards the
aggregator
constraint a condition or restriction
expressed as a
text in a natural language or in a
machine-readable language
in order to declare some of the
semantics of an element
dependency dependency is a relationship
where an element or set of elements
require
other elements for their specification
or
implementation this means that the full
semantics of the dependent elements
are either semantically or structurally
dependent on
the definition of the supplier element
or elements
inheritance inheritance or
generalization
is a taxonomic relationship between a
more general classifier
and a more specific classifier each
instance of a specific classifier
is also an indirect instance of the
general classifier
thus the specific classifier inherits
the features of the more
general classifier let's have a look at
some use cases
consider a typical step-by-step process
of modeling a source code that shows
how we would approach creating a
component diagram
for a program first of all with the help
of forward or reverse
engineering we determine the set of
source code files
of interest and model them as components
for larger systems we can use entire
packages to display groups of files
don't forget about tags that indicate
the version of the source code file in
use you can also specify its author or
the date
and time of the last change we can also
model the compilation dependencies
between
these files using dependencies and now
let's have a look at a step-by-step
process for modeling an
executable release first we define a set
of components
that we want to model typically this
will include some or even
all components that are on a single node
or a distributed system of these sets
of components across all nodes in the
model
it's worth considering the type of each
component
in this set for most systems there is
only a small number of different kinds
of components
such as executable files libraries
tables
other files and documents we can also
use
uml extensibility mechanisms to provide
visual cues for these types it is
important not to forget to consider the
relationship
of each element in the system with its
neighbors
most often this will be associated with
interfaces that are exported or realized
by
certain components and then imported or
used
by others but if we want our model to be
at a
higher level of abstraction then we can
exclude these intermediate interfaces
that
hold such relations together showing
only dependencies
among the components themselves and
finally
in modeling a physical database first
we identify the classes that will
represent
our logical database schema then we
choose a mapping strategy for mapping
these classes to
tables it is also worth taking into
account the physical
distribution of our database because the
mapping strategy will also be affected
by the location
in which you want to store data after
the databases deployment
to visualize define build and document
our mapping we need to create
a component diagram that will contain
these components
as tables uml deployment diagram
illustrates the configuration of runtime
processing nodes
and the components that live on them
deployment diagram is a kind of a
structural diagram used in modeling the
physical
aspects of an object-oriented system
they're often used to
simulate a static representation of a
system deployment
for example topology of the hardware
deployment diagrams show the structure
of the runtime system
they model the elements of physical
hardware and the ways of communicating
between them
they can be used to plan a system
architecture
they can also be useful for documenting
the deployment
of software components or nodes these
diagrams are
important for visualizing defining and
documenting
embedded client server and distributed
systems
as well as managing runtime systems
through
forward or reverse engineering a
deployment diagram
is just a special kind of a class
diagram that focuses
on system nodes graphically deployment
diagram
looks like a collection of vertices and
arcs
deployment diagrams usually contain the
following notation
a 3d box represents a node either
software
or hardware hardware node may be marked
with a
stereotype notation connections between
nodes
are represented with a line with
optional stereotype
notation nodes can reside within other
nodes
the diagram can also reflect
dependencies
associations as well as nodes or
restrictions
these are the steps that are normally
taken to model an embedded system
identify devices and nodes that are
unique to your system
provide visual cues especially for
unusual devices
using uml extensibility mechanisms to
identify system stereotypes with
matching icons
you will also want to distinguish
between processes that contain
software components and devices that at
this level of abstraction do not
directly contain software
model the relationships between these
processors
and devices in a deployment diagram
similarly
specify the relationships between the
components
in the implementation view of your
system and the nodes
in the deployment view of your system if
necessary
expand the capabilities of any smart
devices by modeling
their structure with a more detailed
deployment scheme
here are the steps for modeling a client
server system
identify the nodes that represent the
client and server
processors of your system highlight
those devices that are related to the
behavior of your system for example
you can simulate special devices such as
credit card readers
icon readers and display devices other
than monitors
since placement of the latter in the
systems hardware topology
is likely to be of a great architectural
importance
provide a visual cues for these
processors and devices
through stereotyping model the topology
of these nodes in the deployment diagram
similarly specify the relationships
between the components in the
implementation view of your system
and the nodes in the deployment view of
your system
and here are the steps you will need to
take when modeling a distributed system
identify the devices and processors of
the system as for
simpler client server systems if you
need to reason about the network
performance
or the impact of changes on this network
be sure to simulate
communication devices at a level of
detail that is sufficient
to conduct these estimates pay
particular attention to logical groups
of nodes that you can specify with
packages
where possible use tools that discover
the topology of your system by
walking your system's network if you
need to focus
on the dynamics of your system use the
use case diagram to
indicate the types of behavior you're
interested in and expand these use cases
with
interaction diagrams when modeling a
fully distributed system
it is common to transform or represent
the network itself
as a node that is the internet lan
or one might be depicted as nodes
in the form of a single box rather than
a combination of elements when you
develop a deployment plan for your
company you
might discover that you don't know where
to start and what to focus on
the following checklist can give you
some ideas for planning
your deployment how will your system be
installed who will
install it how long will it take where
the installation can possibly fail
how long can it take to install your
system what backups do you need before
the installation
will data conversion be necessary how
did you know that the installation
was successful if different versions of
the system work simultaneously
how will you resolve the conflicts what
physical sites do you need to deploy
and in what order how will you train
your support and operational staff
will it be necessary to deploy a
production support system so that
support staff will use their own
environment to model problems
how will you train your users what
documentation and in what formats and
languages
do your users as well as support team
and operation specialists need
how will documentation updates be
deployed what existing system
should the new system interact with or
integrate
how reliable should the system be will
any additional equipment be required in
the event of a system failure
what or who will connect or interact
with the system
and how will they do it what software
including the operating systems and
communication protocols will the system
use
what hardware and software will users
interact directly with
pcs network computers browsers etc
how will you control the system after
deployment how secure
should the system be does it needs a
firewall
physically safe equipment etc answering
these questions
will save you a lot of time in the
future and protect you and your team
from unpleasant surprises
during and after the deployment of the
system
uml object diagram is an instance of a
class diagram
it captures a snapshot of the detailed
state of the system
objects and their relationship at a
specific point in time
it can be considered as a special case
of a class diagram or a communication
diagram
the use of the object diagrams is quite
limited
and mainly comes down to demonstrating
examples of data structures
during the project analysis phase you
can create a class diagram to describe
the structure of the system
and then create a set of object diagrams
as
test cases to verify the accuracy and
completeness of the class diagram
prior to creating a class diagram you
can create an
object diagram to find out facts about
specific
model elements and their relationships
or to illustrate
specific examples of the required
classifiers the
object diagram illustrates the relation
between
the instantiated classes and the defined
class
as well as the relationship between the
objects in the model
system at a fixed point in time it's
fair to say
that it's a snapshot of your system at a
certain point in time
which will depict system objects in a
certain state which will directly
represent real instances and prototypes
these diagrams are useful for example
when you want to depict a small part
of a large system in which case the use
of a class diagram would be
an overkill as well as in case you want
to model
recursive relationships or to study the
behavior of a
system at a particular moment in time
the best way to show what an
object diagram looks like is to show an
object diagram
derived from the corresponding class
diagram this humble class diagram
illustrates a simple example in which a
department
depicted consisting of many other
departments
and this object diagram is nothing more
than a detailed
representation of the previous class
diagram with examples
and links let's walk through the basic
notation of an object diagram each
object
is drawn as a rectangle the name of the
object and its class
are usually underlined and separated
with a column the name of the object is
on the left
the name of the class is on the right
the attributes of an object are listed
in a separate compartment
under the name of the class or object
and must indicate
the values assigned to them links in
general are varieties of associations
between classes and are discussed in
detail
in the video about class diagrams since
uml
object diagrams provide a snapshot of
instances
and the relationships between them in
the system we can create
object diagrams by instantiating the
model elements
on class diagrams deployment diagrams
components
and use case diagrams for example we can
represent a part of the company's
structure with
the object diagram a communication
diagram without
any messages can also be called an
object diagram and relationships between
objects can be called
links an object diagram must be a valid
instance of a static class diagram
objects must have classes and
relationships between
objects must be the instances of
associations between classes
that is relationships between objects
will essentially be similar to
relationships between classes let's look
at some steps for modeling object
structures
first of all define the mechanism that
you would like to model
this mechanism can represent some
function or behavior of the part of the
system that you are modeling
which is basically the result of the
interactions between
classes interfaces and other elements
therefore it is necessary to
identify the classes interfaces and
elements for each
mechanism that participate in this model
and determine the relationships between
them
after that consider for example one
scenario that walks
through this mechanism and at a certain
point in time
renders each object that participates in
the mechanism
expand the state and attribute values of
each such
object to understand this scenario a
kind of analogy would be
the mechanical clocks imagine it is noon
and we pretend to freeze the time to
examine the elements of the mechanism
what do they do what do the hour and
minute hands point to
which gears and sprockets are involved
and so on
let's have a look at another example
robot moving behavior here
one object represents the robot itself r
is an instance of a robot and r is
currently
in a state marked moving this object has
a link to w
an instance of the world which is an
abstraction of a model of the world for
the robot
this object is linked with several
objects consisting of
instances of the element that represents
entities that the robot
has identified but has not yet assigned
in
its world view these elements are marked
as part of the global
state of the robot currently w is
associated with two instances of area
one of them a2 is shown with its own
links to the three wall
objects and one door object each of
these walls has an attribute
width and each wall is linked with
neighboring walls
by and large this diagram graphically
shows how the robot
recognizes this enclosed area which has
walls on three sides and a door on the
fourth the next example is
deriving an object structure similar to
communication diagram
in addition to displaying the state of
objects at a certain point in time
an object diagram can also be used for
example to represent
the occurrences of interactions between
classes during the runtime
uml package diagram is a kind of a
structural diagram that shows the
location
and organization of model elements in a
medium scale
and large scale projects a package
diagram can display both
this structure and the dependencies
between subsystems or modules
illustrating various kinds of systems
such as
a layered application for example if the
system is
of a significant size it should be
divided into smaller subsystems
each with its own class diagram in uml
notation these partitions or subsystems
are called packages a package is a group
of elements
of the model and it can also be used in
other uml diagrams packages themselves
can be nested
in other packages which is basically a
uml
version of folders package diagrams are
usually used when it is necessary to
group a related
uml elements and determine the scope of
their names
or when you need to provide a way to
visualize dependencies between
parts of the system as well as to
provide some support
for analysis or determine the
compilation order package diagrams are
used
to structure high-level system elements
when modeling a package diagram you
should bear in mind that
a package is a uml mechanism for
grouping elements
including other packages each package
has its own namespace in which
all names must be unique each model
element
belongs to a single package packages
form
a hierarchy packages are displayed as
rectangles with small
tabs at the top package's name is
normally written on its tab
or dedicated rectangle namespace dotted
lines with arrows
depict dependencies one package is said
to be dependent on
other if changes in that other package
can cause
changes in the first one as well a
system could be depicted
in the form of a package with the
stereotype system
and it represents all the elements of
the model that are relevant
to a particular project you can also
break the system apart into
business systems and application systems
when creating more detailed
models to make them smaller but more
efficient package diagram can also
display the logical architecture of a
system
a subsystem is a group of model elements
that are part
of some larger system since the system
or subsystem
is a stereotypical package it has all
the properties
of the package and it also follows the
rules of the package
and all those model elements that are
contained inside the system or the
subsystem will also belong to the
package and follow
the same rules now what does this word
stereotype
actually mean stereotype is a high-level
classification of an object that gives
some idea of
what the object is classes can be
grouped by
stereotypes their names are written
inside the angle brackets
above the class name stereotype allows
us to extend uml to fit our modeling
needs more specifically
in other words stereotyping a uml
element
makes it act as something that has
specific
properties elements in packages may also
have different visibility of elements of
other packages
and this also needs to be taken into
account during the process of
modeling of a system elements of a
package with public visibility
are available outside the package while
elements with
private visibility are available only
for
other elements within the package in uml
public protected and private
visibilities
correspond to a class that is a public
protected or private a public element is
visible to
all elements that can access the content
of the namespace to which it belongs
public visibility is represented by the
plus sign
a protected element is visible to
elements
related to generalization relationship
to the namespace that
owns it protected visibility is
represented by the hash sign a package
element
is owned by a namespace that is not a
package
and is visible to all elements that are
in the same package
package visibility is marked by a tilde
a private element
is visible only inside the namespace
that
owns it private visibility is
represented
by the minus sign let's look at the
types of dependency relationships
represented by the stereotypes the
element in the client package uses the
public element
in the supplier package the client
depends on the supplier if the package
dependency
is shown without a stereotype then it
should be marked
with a use stereotype public elements of
the supplier namespace are
added as public elements to the client
namespace elements in the client's
namespace can
access all public elements in the
supplier namespace
using unqualified names public supplier
namespace
elements are added as private elements
to the client namespace
elements in the client namespace can
access all public elements in the
supplier namespace
using unqualified names trace normally
represents
a historical development of one element
into another more developed version
usually this is the relationship between
models
not elements public elements of the
supplier package
are combined emerge with the client
package elements
the dependency is used only in meta
modeling and the chance of encountering
it
in the modern object-oriented analysis
and design
is even less than encountering an
elephant in the central london
next we will analyze an example diagram
of the
order tracking scenario for an online
store in this diagram the
track order module is responsible for
providing tracking information for
product ordered by
our customers the types of customers are
encrypted inside the tracking number
truck order module
refers to the system and updates the
current delivery status
for the customer based on the
description of the project
first we must determine what packages
will be present
in the system and figure out the
relationships between them
so how to determine which packages do we
need to model the system
suppose that we have a module that
tracks an
order it could be some sort of a
tracking module and
in order to perform its duty it must
communicate with
another module in order to figure out
the details of the order
let's call this module order details
after receiving the details of the order
it needs to know the shipping details so
let's introduce
a shipping module and now let's
determine the dependencies between them
the track order module must receive the
order details from the order details
module
in response order details module
requires to know the
information provided by the client two
modules communicate with each other
which provides the access dual
dependency to learn the shipping
information
the shipping module can import the truck
order module
to make the navigation easier finally
the truck order
is dependent on the ui framework and
this completes our order processing
subsystem design composite structure
diagram
contains classes interfaces packages
and their relationships and it provides
a logical representation of a software
system or its part
this diagram is one of the new artifacts
added in uml
2.0 and it shows the internal structure
including parts and connectors of a
structured classifier
or collaboration the composite structure
diagram plays a role
similar to the class diagram but allows
you to
delve into details of the internal
structure of
multiple classes and show the
interactions between them you can
graphically represent
inner classes and parts and show
associations both
between classes and within them in other
words
composite structure diagrams show the
internal
parts of a class the part's name is
usually constructed
with part's name then colon then
parts type with multiplicity stated
inside the square brackets
aggregated classes are parts of a class
but
parts are not necessarily classes a part
is any element that is used to make up
the containing class
suppose we are modeling a system for an
online store
in which customers can join a loyalty
program that provides them with
some benefits discounted shipping for
example in order to allow such a feature
we expanded the customer object so now
we have a regular customer and a member
of
our loyalty program let's start by
simulating an
online store using a class diagram we
have a class 4
item which can be aggregated by the
order class
which is composed by the customer class
which itself is composed by
the store manager class we have many
objects
that end up within other objects on the
diagram
everything looks as if it ends up inside
the store manager so
we can create a composite structure
diagram to clearly demonstrate
what this manager consists of composite
structure diagram
shows us a clear picture of the store
manager from
its own point of view instead of this
system as a whole
store manager directly contains two
types of objects
customer and item as indicated by the
two composition arrows in the class
diagram
the composite structure diagram here
shows the inclusion
of customer subtypes explicitly please
note that the type of both parts
is declared as customer because the
store treats both
objects as customer objects we also see
a connector that shows the relationship
between
item and order order is not contained
directly in the store manager class but
we can show relationships with
parts nested in the object that it
aggregates
the question is do these two diagrams
essentially describe the same thing or
have the same meaning well in the class
diagram the relationship between the
description
and pricing is ambiguous strictly
speaking they are not
exactly the same the class diagram shows
that description
will have a reference to the pricing
object but this does not specify whether
the link between the two objects
is contained inside the item explicitly
if we use a composite structure diagram
the relationship between the description
and pricing objects becomes obvious
specific implementations of an object's
activity can be clearly
modeled composite structure diagrams are
good for describing aggregation but in
this case
models will also need to contain
references to
objects outside the class that we are
modeling
references to external objects are shown
with a
dashed rectangle even if they refer to
an object outside the class
the link itself is inside the model
class
and it is an important step in
demonstrating its
implementation the key object of
composite structure
specified in the uml 2.0 are structured
classifiers
parts ports connectors and
collaborations
collaboration describes the structure of
collaborating parts and their roles in
the interaction
and is used when we want to determine
only those roles and connections that
are necessary to achieve a specific goal
of such
collaboration for example the purpose of
a collaboration may be to define the
roles of components of a classifier
having identified the main roles the
collaboration
simplifies the structure and clarifies
the behavior of
elements in the model itself in this
example the wheels
and the engine are parts of the
collaboration
and front axle and rear axle are
connectors
a car is a composite structure that
shows parts and connections between
parts
a part is a diagram element that
represents
a set of one or more instances owned by
a structured classifier
a part describes the role of the
instance in the classifier
we can create parts in the structure
compartment of the classifier
and in several uml diagrams such as
composite structure diagram class
diagram object diagram
component diagram deployment diagram and
package diagram a
port defines the point of interaction
between the classifier instance
and its environment or between the
behavior of the classifier
and its internal parts composite
structure diagram supports the notation
for
provided and required interfaces if
necessary
interfaces can be shown or hidden in the
diagram
a line that represents the relationships
within the model
is called a connector when modeling the
internal structure of a classifier
we can use a connector to indicate a
link
between two or more instances of a part
or a port a connector defines the
relationships between the objects or
instances that
are associated with the roles in the
same structured classifier and
defines the communication between those
roles
as an example here's a simplified
composite structure diagram for a
computer system which
includes the following components power
supply unit
hard disk dvd motherboard central
processing unit
and memory module you can pause the
video here to study the diagram
profile diagram is one of the uml
structural diagrams it is well known for
providing a general extension mechanism
for customizing uml models for specific
domains
and platforms profiles are defined using
stereotypes
tag value definitions and constraints
that apply to specific
elements of the model such as classes
attributes
operations and actions a profile is a
set of extensions that jointly configure
uml for a specific domain for example
aerospace
medical or financial or specific
platform such as
j2ee or net profile diagrams
have three major types of extension
mechanisms
stereotypes tags and constraints
stereotypes allow us to increase the
vocabulary of
uml you can add and create new model
elements
derived from the existing ones but
having more specific properties that
are suitable for a specific domain
stereotypes are used to
introduce new building blocks that speak
the language of your domain
and look primitive this allows you to
introduce
new graphical symbols for example when
modeling a network you may need
annotation for router switch hub etc
a stereotype allows you to make these
things appear
as primitive as possible why would you
need that
for example a box labeled with a
stereotype button makes more sense than
a picture of green rooster that was
added to the schema
just because someone ran out of
meaningful symbols
tags are used to extend the properties
of uml so you can add additional
information to the specification
of a model element this allows you to
specify
keyword value pairs of a model where
keywords
are attributes tagged values are
graphically displayed as strings
enclosed by the curly braces for example
imagine a team that is responsible for
assembling testing and deploying a
system for them
it is necessary to monitor the version
and
test results of the main subsystem and
this is where
tags come in handy tags can also be
useful to add properties to the model
such as code generation version control
configuration management and authorship
constraints are properties
used for semantics or conditions that
should always be
satisfied they allow us to expand the
semantics of the uml
building blocks by adding new protocols
a constraint is displayed as a string
enclosed by the square brackets next to
the corresponding element for example
when developing a real-time system it is
necessary to supplement
the model with some necessary
information such as response time for
instance
constraints may be placed on attributes
derived attributes
and associations they can also be
attached to
one or more model elements shown as a
node
as an alternative to creating a new
matter model
you can also expand and modify the uml
metamodel according to your requirements
in uml this
is called a lightweight extension based
on stereotypes and
profiles a uml profile can be defined in
one of the following ways
creation of a new meta model extension
and modification of the uml metamodel
extension of the uml meta-model with
language inherent
mechanisms uml 2.0 allows you to use
arbitrary data structures for extended
elements which means that
wider and more accurate extensions of
the model
are now possible the profile mechanism
is not a first class extension mechanism
because
it does not allow changing existing or
creating
new meta models profile only allows
adaptation or customization of an
existing meta model in uml
2.0 or above profiles can also be
dynamically combined so that
multiple profiles can be applied on the
same
model at the same time a stereotype can
extend
from one or more meta classes such
extension is depicted as an arrow with a
continuous
align and filled arrowhead that goes in
the direction
from the stereotype to the metaclass
stereotypes can be presented
in the form of text or graphics the
normal class box can also be replaced by
the icon
for example people often use these three
stereotype class representations to
model
the mvc software infrastructure to use
stereotypes in a specific
application you must first integrate a
profile containing stereotypes you do
this with a dashed arrow its open
arrowhead
is pointing away from the application
package
towards the profile this arrow is marked
with a keyword
apply a profile is applied to another
package to make stereotypes
in the profile available for this
package
this diagram shows the network
telecommunications
and software profiles that apply to the
it
company suite in this diagram we define
the ejb
profile as a package the bean itself
expands from the component metamodel
as an abstract bean an abstract bean can
be instantiated as an
entity bean or session bean ejb has two
types of remote and
home interfaces ejb also contains a
special kind of an artifact called a jar
file for storing
a collection of java code use case
diagrams are fairly simple
they summarize some of the relationships
between use cases
actors and systems but they don't show
the order in which steps to achieve the
goals of each use case are taken
they usually contain only a few simple
figures
therefore if you have more than 20 use
cases you are probably using the diagram
incorrectly there are many different uml
diagrams that serve
various purposes very often it is
possible to describe the details of a
system
using other uml diagrams and link them
together with use cases because use
cases represent only the functional
requirements of the system
other requirements such as business
rules quality of service requirements
and implementation restrictions must be
presented separately
again with other uml diagrams use case
diagrams are usually constructed
at an early stage of development and are
often used for the following purposes
to specify a system context to capture
system requirements
to validate system architecture and to
drive
implementation and generate test cases
and usually
all this is developed by analysts
together with
domain experts so what does the use case
diagram
consists of actor in a broad sense
one who interacts with the system and in
most cases
one who creates a use case actor is
usually drawn as a little genderless
humanoid with a name on it
acta plays a role in the business
process quite similar to the concept
of a user but the user and this is
important can play
different roles for instance a professor
can be a lecturer
at the uni as well as a scientist in
some kind of a research lab so in this
case the professor plays two roles in
two different systems actor triggers use
cases
in other words actors interaction with
the system
and how the system reacts to those
interactions
form the use case acta also has some
expectations from interactions with the
system if we expect one thing but get
something completely different
then the system function responsible for
the use case
may have been either improperly modeled
or improperly implemented
use case it is a system function or a
process
that can be either automatic or manual
the name is usually constructed from a
combination of verb
and a noun or phrases that guide to
do something each actor must be
associated with a use case
while some use cases might not be
associated with actors
use cases determine the expected
behavior that is
what should happen but they don't
describe how
to make this happen use cases can be
indicated
in text or graphic form for example in
the form
of a use case diagram the main point of
modeling the use cases
is to help us to design the system from
the perspective of the
end user by indicating all possible
actions of the system that
might be externally visible
communication link actors can be
connected with use cases
via associations indicating that the
actor
and the use case communicate with each
other through messages
this is graphically shown with a solid
line system boundaries for large
and complex systems each module may be
the boundary of the system but
potentially it may be the entire system
for instance
if we'll have a look at an erp system
each one of the modules such as
personnel
payroll or accounting can form a system
boundary for use cases
specific to each of these business
functions the entire system can span
through all of these modules displaying
the overall boundary
of the system use cases form various
kinds of relationships the duty of
defining the relationships between
two use cases falls on the shoulders of
software
analysts of the use case diagram reusing
an existing use case with
other types of relationships reduces the
overall effort
required to develop a system let's look
at the main relationships between
use cases use case diagram illustrates a
set of use cases for the system
an example subjects and relationships
between
subjects and use cases extends
indicates that for example use case
invalid password
may include under the conditions
specified in the extension
the behavior specified in the base use
case
login into account imagine that we have
a use case that describes the
interaction of an actor with an account
for example
the possibility of a login the basic use
case is extended by
two other use cases for example the
already mentioned
invalid password in which case the
system will react in one way
and on the contrary correct password in
which case the system will most likely
react differently
extensions are important because they
show additional functionality or system
behavior
this type of relationship is used to
include optional behavior of the use
case that
extends the base use case in our example
the student requests
a schedule and this requires the
extension of the base
use case request schedule with the use
case
search when one use case is shown using
the functionality of another use case
the relationship between them
is indicated by their include stereotype
this type of relationship means that an
instance of the base use case will
include the behavior as specified in the
child use case
and it is indicated by a dashed arrow
with its tip pointing
to the child use case include adds
additional functionality not specified
in the base use case
and is used to add general behavior from
the included use case
to the basis case in order to support
the reusage
of the common behavior generalization or
inheritance
this is a parent-child relationship
between use cases where the child use
case is an extension of its parent
use case generalization is depicted by a
solid line with a triangular arrow hat
pointing at the parent use case in this
type of relationship
the child use case inherits the behavior
and semantic component
from the parent use case a child use
case may add or
override the behavior of its parent in
this example
the parent use case search has two
children
search by lecturer and search by date
this use case diagram
depicts a car sale system and you can
probably notice that
even such a complicated system can be
described
with just 10 use cases here you can
observe extensions
inclusions and associations that connect
actors with use cases now a couple of
tips to model a use case diagram more
efficiently in case you will decide to
do so in your project
always structure and organize a use case
diagram
from the perspective of actors use cases
should start
off simple and at the highest view
possible only then
we can move towards refinement and high
digitalization
use case diagrams are based on
functionality and
therefore should focus on what and not
on the how
activity diagram is another important
uml behavioral diagram
used to describe the dynamic aspects of
a system
activity diagram is essentially an
extended version
of a flowchart that models the
transition from one activity to another
and it shows how system activities are
coordinated to provide a service that
can be at a different
level of abstraction first of all let's
go over the basic notation of the
elements in the diagram and move on to
the examples
initial node it starts the flow when the
activity is called
from the outside control flow it shows
the sequence of
execution of flow action a task to be
performed
decision node it represents a test
condition to ensure
that the control flow or object flow
only goes down
one path merge node it merges the
various
threads that were created after the
decision node
fork node splits behavior into a set
of parallel or concurrent flows of
activities
join node it combines several parallel
flows
usually separated by a fork node object
represents an object in a thread that is
being acted upon
this is an optional element of the
diagram but
in some cases it is necessary to show
the
object initiating the execution of
activities
or being created as a result of some
early initiation
activity final note it terminates all
flows
in an activity swimlane a way to group
activities performed by the same actor
on an activity diagram
or simply group them in a single thread
the following steps of the activity
diagram
describe the workflow for creating a
document in a text editor
open the text editor create a document
save the document enter the text if
graphics are necessary
import them into the document if a table
or a spreadsheet
is necessary create the required table
or spreadsheet
and import it into the document save the
document
print the document exit the text editor
seems pretty logical and simple now
let's imagine that we were given
a task to simulate the order processing
workflow using an activity diagram the
description of the process
is as follows once the order is received
the activities
split into two parallel flows one
fulfills and sends the order and the
other process
the invoices on the order processing
side the delivery method is determined
depending
on the conditions of the order and
transformed into action
overnight delivery or regular delivery
after sending the invoice for the goods
the payment process side is going to
receive payment
hopefully finally to parallel flows join
and finalize
the order processing another example is
the process
for student enrolment in programming
courses
a student decides that he or she wants
to become a
super coding guru goes online discovers
some online courses
and commits to enroll then fills in the
registration form on the company's
website
if the form is filled in correctly then
the student is registered
if not the student is notified to
correct the errors and try again
after that the student can check out our
free introductory course
after completing or skipping it the
student can start
our full-fledged course straight away
finally the student
needs to pay for the course success but
there is another interesting way
to add clarity to the diagram i suspect
that the person who has invented the
first activity diagram was probably a
passionate swimmer because
he or she introduced the concept of a
swim lane as a part of the diagram
swimlane
is a way of grouping activities
performed by the same actor
in a single thread let's have a look at
the activity diagram that describes the
business process
of onboarding a new client first of all
we
reach out to our potential client and
arrange a meeting
depending on whether there will be a
meeting and whether it will be in our
company's office
or in the client's office we are
preparing either a conference room
or just take our laptop with us but
regardless
of where the meeting is going to take
place we know that the client
wants to meet with us after the meeting
we'll normally send a follow-up letter
to the client we just had a meeting with
decision point if we have a deal then we
prepare the contract
and we also add the comment that there
is another
a separate activity diagram that
reflects this process
and needs to be followed we send the
contract to the client
and we get to the point where the
process finalizes
by the way we come here even if we
didn't get the deal
and here is a schema of the same process
but this time
we're using swimlane you can see that
now it looks much more accurate because
this time the process is divided into
areas of responsibility for the
salesperson
who organizes the appointment as well as
writes a follow-up letter
to the client and the consultant who
prepares the presentation for the client
holds a meeting and crafts and sends the
contract
and a secretary whose task includes
preparing the conference room in case
the meeting takes place
in our company's own office the behavior
of an entity
is not only a direct result of the input
but it also depends on its preceding
state
uml state machine diagram or sometimes
referred to
simply as state diagram or state machine
or state chart
shows the various states of entities
state machine diagrams can also show
how an entity reacts to various events
moving from one state to another and can
be used to model the dynamic nature of
the system
state machine diagram is typically used
to describe the state-dependent behavior
of an object an object reacts
differently to the same event
depending on the state it is in although
state diagrams are mainly applied to
objects
they can be applied to any element that
changes behavior in relation to
other objects such as actors use cases
methods subsystems systems etc
and they're usually used in conjunction
with
sequence diagrams state machine diagram
describes
all events as well as states and
transitions for a
single object a sequence diagram
describes the events for a single
interaction
across all objects involved let's have a
look at the notation used in the state
machine diagrams
state is a constraint or a situation in
the life cycle of an object
in which a constraint holds the object
performs
a certain activity or expects an event
an event is a significant occurrence
allocated in time and space
in the context of states an event is the
occurrence of a stimulus that can
initiate a state transition guard
condition
is evaluated after the state transition
trigger
event occurs you can have several
transitions
from the same initial state and with the
same
event trigger if only the guard
condition do not
overlap a guard condition is evaluated
only once
for the transition at the time when the
event occurs
the boolean expression can refer to the
state of the object
a transition is a relationship between
two states
indicating that an object from the first
state will enter the second state when
the specified event occurs
and the specified conditions are
satisfied
an action is an executable atomic
computation that changes the state of
the model
or returns a value a state is a point in
the life cycle of a model element
that satisfies some condition where some
specific
action is performed or where some event
is expected there are also two states
with a specific predefined role first
one is the initial state which is
indicated by a solid circle
a transition from the state will show
the first
real state and the final state which is
shown
as a concentric circle in case of an
open-loop state machine
an object may terminate before the
system terminates while a closed-loop
state machine
diagram does not have a final state if
it is the case then the object lives
until the entire system terminates
events are occurrences that cause
objects to transition from one state to
another
an event can be one of four types signal
event corresponds to the arrival of an
asynchronous message or signal call
event
corresponds to the arrival of a
procedural call to an operation
time event occurs after a specified
time has elapsed and change event
occurs whenever the specified condition
is met
transition lines depict movement from
one state to another
each transition line is marked with an
event that triggers
the transition considering a system as a
collection of states and transitions
between states
is very useful for describing complex
behavior understanding state transitions
is an important part of system analysis
and design transitions between states
occur
as follow the item is in its original
state
event occurs action is performed
element enters target state multiple
transitions
occur either when different events lead
to the termination of the state
or when there are guard conditions on
their transitions
transition without an event an action is
known as
automatic transition action is an
executable
atomic computation which includes
operation calls
the creation or destruction of another
object or
sending of a signal to an object the
action is associated
with the transitions during which the
action is not
interruptable for example entry or exit
this diagram shows the state of the my
bk
copy object from the book copy class
entry action is any action that is
executed
whenever an object enters the specified
state
exit action is any action that is
executed whenever an object
leaves the state now let's talk about
substates
a simple state is a state that does not
have a substructure
a state that has substates or nested
states
is called a composite state substates
can be nested at any level
a nested state can have at most one
initial state and one final state
substates are used to simplify complex
state diagrams showing that some states
are possible
only within a specific context state
diagrams are often used for
deriving test cases here is a list of
possible test
ideas idle state receives to hot
event idle state receives to called
event the calling startup state receives
the compressor start event calling ready
state
receives a fun run event the calling
run state receives ok event calling
run state receives a failure event
failure state
receives error reset event heating state
receives an okay event heating state
receives a
failure event nested states are
necessary when
the activity involves concurrent
sub-activities
in this diagram an auction was modeled
with two concurrent sub states bit
processing
and payment limit authorization in this
example
the state machine first entering the
auction requires a fork at the start
into two separate threads each substate
has an
exit state to mark the end of the thread
if there is no abnormal exit which is
cancellation or rejection
then the exit from the composite state
occurs
when both substates exit unless it's
specified otherwise when a transition
enters a composite state the action of
the nested state machine
starts over again at the initial state
unless the transition is aimed
directly at the substate history states
allow the state machine to
re-enter the last substate that was
active prior to leaving
the composite state a history state is
indicated by a circle with
the letter h inside uml sequence
diagrams
are interaction diagrams that detail how
operations are performed
they capture the interaction between
objects in the context of
collaboration and show how elements
interact
over time and are organized with respect
to
object horizontally and time vertically
the horizontal axis shows elements that
participate in the interaction
and they can appear in any order
typically
objects participating in an operation
are listed from left to right
according to when they participate in
the message sequence the vertical axis
shows the progressing time but note that
time in the sequence diagram
is denoted in the context of the
execution order that is the sequence
itself
and not the actual duration there are
timing diagrams just for that
the vertical space in the interaction
diagram has nothing to do with
the duration of interaction as an
example we will consider the hotel
booking service the object that
initiates the message sequence
is the reservation window note that
class and object diagrams are static
model views
but interaction diagrams are dynamic
let's look at the basic notation of the
sequence diagram
actor a type of role played by the
instance
that interacts with the subject for
example by exchanging
signals and data actors represent the
roles
played by users external equipment or
other actors actor does not necessarily
represent a specific physical entity but
simply
a specific role of some entity a person
can play the role of several different
actors
and conversely an actor may be
represented by
multiple different people lifeline he
represents
an individual participant in the
interaction
and displays the passage of time
activation
the thin rectangle on the lifeline
indicates the period during which the
element performs an operation
top and bottom of the rectangle are
aligned with the start and end
of a specific function call message used
to call procedures
execute operations or designate
individual nested control flows
one end of the arrow always touches the
control focus or lifeline of the client
object that triggers the message
the tip of the arrow points at the
lifeline of the object
that receives the message and takes
action as a result
at the same time this object also often
receives a control focus becoming active
the message can be synchronous depicted
with a
filled arrow when the client sends a
message for example
to the server and waits for a response
before doing anything else
and a synchronous depicted with a
regular arrow when the client continues
to perform
operations without waiting for a
response
return message return message identifies
the specific communication between the
lifelines of an interaction
and represents the transfer of
information to the caller
of the corresponding message self
message a participant
sends a message or command to itself
create message
in the case of creating a participant we
draw an arrow pointing at the
participant's rectangle
if the participant will perform
something immediately after his creation
then straight after the participants a
rectangle
we will need to draw the activation
destroy message
the destruction of a participant is
indicated by a large
x with an arrow pointing from the
participant
that initiates the destruction towards
the one
that is going to be destroyed if the x
is drawn at the end
of the participant's lifeline and there
is no arrow from
another object then this means that the
object deletes itself
in other words self-destructs note
or comment gives the ability to attach
various nodes to
elements a comment carries no semantic
force but
may contain useful information focus of
control
this is essentially any point in
interaction where
something happens and it is drawn as a
tall
thin rectangle on the lifeline since the
control focus
represents a period during which an
element is performing
some operation the top and bottom of the
rectangle
are aligned with the initiation and
completion time respectively
uml 2.0 introduces sequence or
interaction fragments a sequence
fragment is
represented as a box called a combined
fragment that includes some of the
interactions within
the sequence diagram the fragment
operator in the top left corner
indicates the type of fragment which can
be
one of the following alt multiple
alternative
fragments only the one whose condition
is true
is executed message or group of messages
is separated from each other by
horizontal dashed line
this type is used to simulate
conditional statements
like if then else and select statements
case or switch opt the fragment is
executed only if the provided condition
is true
and it is a call to an additional
message or
group of messages under some condition
it is similar to the old fragment
when the shorthand conditional statement
if then is used
par parallel message processing message
or group of messages processed in
parallel are separated from each other
by
horizontal dashed lines loop as obvious
as it looks
it is used to simulate loops break early
termination of message processing on
condition
used as a part of other fragments
usually
loop critical exclusively processed
message or group of messages used as a
part of
other fragments usually par implies the
suspension of
any messages processing in a more
general fragment for the duration
of message processing inside the
critical subfragment
neck message or event generated as a
result
of the inability to process another
received message
for example if the time for entering the
password has expired
then instead of returning the password
the timeout message will be generated
a third it's when a message or group of
messages
executed after some condition has been
pre-checked
if the condition is negative then no
message is sent
in programming this technique is always
used to localize errors strict
sequential message handling
consecutively processed messages
are separated from each other by
horizontal dashed line
and processed strictly in turn from top
to bottom
sec non-strict sequential message
processing
messages are separated from each other
by horizontal dashed lines
and can be processed in any order except
for messages
received by one object ignore messages
that can potentially occur in the
fragment and
that are listed after the word ignore in
curly braces
will be ignored ref a reference to a
portion
of the interaction defined elsewhere
perhaps in a different diagram
this element is similar to predefined
processes
in flowcharts or interaction overview
diagrams
sd used to surround the entire sequence
diagram
now that we know what's what let's use
our knowledge to model
a script that consists of some use cases
in our case customer requirements are
described as
use cases that are formalized in the
script
as a reminder a use case is a set of
interactions between
external actors and a system to be more
precise
a specification of a sequence of actions
including
variants that a system or object can
perform
interacting with actors of the system a
script
is a thread that describes a sequence of
events that occur
during one particular execution of a
system
that is often represented by sequence
diagram for example
in this sequence diagram there are two
scenarios
the main one and the alternative one
following the main scenario
the buyer enters the author's name in
the search box and
clicks the search button the system
validates the search query
if the validation passes the system
searches the catalog
for the author's books when the search
is complete the system displays
its results an alternative scenario is
rather short
if the buyer did not enter the author's
name but clicked on the search button
then
the system displays an error message
similar to sequence diagrams
communication diagrams are subtypes of
interaction diagrams and
show how objects interact with each
other communication diagrams or
as they were called prior to uml 2.0
collaboration diagrams essentially are
the extensions of
object diagrams that show these objects
along with the messages that objects
sent to each other the main purpose of
communication diagrams
is model the messages passing between
objects or roles that deliver
the functionalities of use cases and
operations
model mechanisms within the
architectural design of the system
capture interactions that show the past
messages between
objects and roles in collaborations
model
alternative scenarios within use cases
or operations that involve the
collaboration of
various objects and interactions and
support
for identification of objects hence
classes
and their attributes in this case
message parameters
and operations messages that are
involved
in use cases let's analyze a simple
example of a communication diagram where
objects
for example actors in use cases are
drawn
as rectangles the objects are object 1
object 2 object n minus 1 and so on
until
object m messages passed between these
objects
are represented by a labeled arrows that
start with
the sending object or actor and with the
receiving object
examples of messages passed between
objects are marked as
message 1 message 2 message
3 etc where the numeric prefix of the
message name
indicates its order in sequence object 1
first sends message 1 to object 2.
object 2 in turn sends object n
minus 1 message 2 and so on
messages that objects sent to themselves
are referred to
as loops for example message five or
here is
another example hotel room reservations
each message in the diagram
has a sequence number the top level
message is number one
messages sent during the same call have
the same
decimal prefix but surfaces 1 2 etc
depending on when they occur
communication and sequence diagrams
are similar they are semantically
equivalent it means
they represent the same information and
we can turn
a communication diagram into a sequence
diagram
and vice versa the main difference
between them is that
in the communication diagram the
elements are organized
according to space and in the sequence
diagram
according to time so in which case we
would want to use a communication
diagram instead of a sequence diagram
first of all communication diagrams are
very useful
for visualizing relationships between
objects that collaborate with each other
to perform a specific
task this is difficult to determine from
a sequence diagram
in addition communication diagram can
also help to determine the accuracy of a
static model
for example class diagram here is a real
world example where we can
compare both diagrams in action the
process of returning a book
to the library imagine a student brings
a book to the library and a librarian
brings up records to check whether the
book was returned on time and whether
the borrowing period was
exceeded in that case there may be a
fine in essence both diagrams contain
objects and messages and it becomes
obvious that it is much easier to
determine the time ordering of messages
by looking at the sequence diagram but
it's easier to see the relationships
between
objects by looking at the communication
diagram
objects involved in communication are of
two types
supplier and client supplier objects are
objects that supply the method that is
being called and therefore
receive the message client objects call
methods on supplier objects
and therefore send messages connectors
drawn between
objects in communication diagram are
links that
allow to establish relationships between
objects
and show the ability of objects to send
messages to each other
if an object sends message to itself
then
such a link is represented as a loop
icon
the loop can be seen on both the ui
object
and the transaction object messages in
communication diagrams are shown as
arrows pointing from the client object
to
the supplier object typically messages
represent a client
invoking an operation on a supplier
object message icons have
one or several messages associated with
them messages are composed of
message text prefixed with a sequence
number this sequence number
indicates the time ordering of the
message for example
in this diagram we can follow the
sequence numbers
to determine the order of messages
between objects the first message in the
communication diagram
is always numbered one the second two
and so on we can indicate that the
message is nested within the parent
message by
adding a decimal point and additional
digit to the parent's
ordinal for example the message carl amt
can borrow that is calculate for how
long the book can be borrowed
is the first nested message in the
enquire
borrower literally request the details
of a person who borrows
and is given a serial number 1.1
the second nested message in inquire
borrower is
display invalid msg that is display
an error message therefore is given a
sequence
number 1.2 let's look at the example of
transition from a sequence diagram to a
communication diagram the client creates
a transaction and performs an operation
with messages a
d and o after that another two
transactions
put values of p1 p2 p3
and p4 to the database more after that
the client receives a message that the
transaction was
completed and finally the transaction is
destroyed
and now the same sequence of operations
only on
the communication diagram the client
creates a transaction
performs an operation with messages a d
and o
next to transactions put values of p1
p2 p3 p4 to the database and after that
the client receives a message that the
transaction was completed finally the
transaction
is destroyed there are a few things to
watch out for
control focus also known as execution
occurrence or
activation shown as a tall thin
rectangle denoting the period
during which an element performs an
operation the top and bottom
of the rectangle match the start time
and
end time respectively in a communication
diagram
the control focus is explicit and can
thus
be represented by the message nest
numbering
finally i would like to show a
communication diagram in a format
that is also used in some occasions and
is called the reliability diagram format
we can model
objects and instances of actors in
communication diagrams
along with links and messages describing
how they are related
and how they interact the deposit
element in the diagram
describing the recycling machine system
describes
what happens to the particular objects
in terms of how the objects
interact send messages to each other and
so on you can create a communication
diagram for each
variant of the use case flow events uml
interaction overview diagram illustrates
the flow of control
of the interactions with the notes that
consist
of interactions or interaction
occurrences in other words it is a high
level abstraction that illustrates
the flow of activity between diagrams
basically
overview interaction diagram is like an
activity diagram
in which the elements were replaced by
small sequence diagrams
or is like a sequence diagram broken
down by the markup of the activity
diagram
that illustrates the flow of control
here are the main nodes used in the
diagram
initial node decision node fork node
join node and activity final node
there are several node types such as
interaction diagram
marked as sd sequence diagram of any
kind it may appear in line as
an activity invocation reference to the
interaction
marked as ref also called interaction
use
with its help large and complex sequence
diagrams
can be greatly simplified it is also
common to
reuse some interaction between several
other interactions
so let's analyze the diagram step by
step the diagram shows an example of an
onboarding process the employee must
first accept or
reject the offer note that second option
does not contribute to the onboarding
process
after accepting the offer the employee
must register with
hr and apply for a company car after
both actions were completed the employee
must actually begin to work
for example on board new customers if
the employee doesn't do that after a
certain probation period
the contract gets terminated here are a
few
more examples to examine here is how we
can depict the interaction
with the code lock on the door using the
interaction of view diagram
interaction use and the code first
appears with the argument invalid code
then the interaction follows indicate
that the code is
entered incorrectly which is displayed
on the diagram
using the built-in fragment from the
sequence diagram
the following is a decision node with a
valid pin code
interaction constraint this means that
only if the code is entered correctly
the grant access interaction follows
this is followed by an interaction use
let's call it door opening the door is
now unlocked
end of story but if the code was entered
incorrectly
nothing will happen however we'll also
be
redirected to the activity final note
and here is a simple hotel room
reservation scheme however
this time we utilize only the
interaction use notes to provide
a high level of abstraction register the
website
select available room type and dates
there are no rooms available for these
dates
we are redirected back to where we can
choose
other rooms or dates if all goes well
then we proceed to checkout
if everything is fine there as well the
room is booked
of course this is a primitive example
and we would potentially append the
diagram with many more additional
interactions but
it still gives you a sense of how the
interaction
overview diagram works timing diagrams
are uml
interaction diagrams that are used when
the main purpose of a diagram is to
indicate the intervals between state
changes of
various objects timing diagrams focus
on conditions changing within and among
lifelines along the time axis and
describe the behavior of both
individual classifiers and their
interactions focusing
attention on time of events causing
changes in the modeled
conditions of the lifelines transition
from one state to another
is a change in the level of the lifeline
during the period of time
when the object is in a given state the
timeline runs
parallel to that state a change in state
is displayed as a vertical
change from one level to another the
reason for the change
as in the case of a state or sequence
diagram
is the receipt of a message or request
of an event
that causes a change this so-called
stimulus
or it could be that the change of the
system state occurred by itself
triggered by the passage of time this
diagram shows
alternative notations of the uml
timeline diagram
in particular the state of the object
depicted between
two horizontal lines that intersect each
other on
each change of the state the lifeline is
an element that represents an
individual participant in the
interaction usually it is
horizontally aligned to be read from
left
to right multiple lifelines may be
stacked within the same frame to model
the interaction between them the state
timeline
is a set of valid states of elements and
time
states are stacked on the left margin of
the lifeline from top to bottom
it is possible to stack several
lifelines of different
objects in the same timing diagram
placing
one lifeline above the other messages
sent
from one object to another can be
displayed using simple arrows the stats
and the end points of each arrow
indicate
when each message was sent and when it
was
received the state lifeline indicates
the change of
state of an element over time the x-axis
displays elapsed time in any selected
units
while the y-axis is marked with a list
of states the value lifeline
illustrates the change of elements of
value over time
the x-axis displays elapsed time in any
selected units
similar to the state lifeline the value
is written between a pair of horizontal
lines that intersect
each time the value changes we can use
the length of the timeline to show
how long the object remains in a certain
state reading it from left to right
in this diagram the login event is
received after
three units of time from the start of
the sequence
to show relative times we can mark a
specific
instance in time using a variable name
this diagram
marks the time when sendmail event was
received using the
letter t we can use a relative
timestamps in constraints to indicate
that a message must be received within
a certain amount of time state and value
lifelines can be stacked together
in any combination messages can be
transmitted
from one lifeline to another each state
or value transition
can have a certain time limited event
which
indicates when it should happen and a
duration constraint that indicates
how long the object will be in that
state or will be affected by
the certain values here is an example
where we
simulate a car park system using this
sequence diagram
it shows the consistency of the model
between
two interaction diagrams the timing
diagram
must always match the sequence diagram
and
state diagram in order to achieve this
we can attach
states to the lifeline of each object in
the sequence diagram
in this case we can derive the
corresponding timing diagram
much easier by checking the messages
sent between
objects against the states attached to
the lifeline so
here is the same car park system
presented in the form
of a timing diagram